committed by all means of communication
back to star talk and by the college
we're going to find you you're the colin
jost that's right and twitter yeah so
it's like and i've been enjoying all
your tweets about mars
curiosity it's so it's really cool thank
you thank you a lot of great mars facts
but i did not know
so before the break you left off with a
question who's it from uh this is a
question from drew mcdowell drew
mcdowell so he'd asked about the star
trek the voyage home star trek four
which has been dubbed save the whales
right right that's the
the subtitle of that show that's right
where they go back in time to the
present day
of the time of the film so it's 1984 i
think it was or 85
and so he wants to know is there an
actual speed with which you can swing by
slingshot past the sun such as what they
did in that show right in the movie in
order to go back in time right and it's
it says can you use the sun's pull but
is there a safe enough distance that it
wouldn't just pull you in yeah so first
of all you cannot do what they did in
the show in the movie regardless
regardless right so so just with nip
that one in the bud yes okay so and
the only way you could do something like
that is if you had vastly more powerful
gravity than the sun
and you needed a the fabric of space and
time has to be so warped
that
in fact there's a colleague of mine who
studies this his name is rich god in
fact he's been on star talk before he
wrote a book called time travel in
einstein's universe and he found any a
solution to einstein's equations that
allows backwards time travel with the
kind of a slingshot trajectory but not
around the sun the sun does not disturb
the fabric of space and time nearly
enough
what's the kind of thing that would two
black holes that are in orbit around
each other and so you'd have to do a
kind of a
a wiggly path around these black holes
and you can end up in the past
of your own
world line before you had left to go on
that trip well yeah it's it's a very woe
moment and so star trek it was more
exciting to do it around the edge of the
sun
because visually rather than just two
black things in space which is already
black
but uh in principle they but in fact i
don't know that this equation had been
discovered at the time the movie was
conceived they surely would have tapped
it they've got very good writers first
for star trek so so yeah now in terms of
how close you can get to the sun the the
ship unless it had deflector shields
working against
thermal energy uh the ship would have
just vaporized yeah
and